do
wir waren dort im rahmen der reportage
für das westschweizer fernsehen
hans kabel war zuständig für unsere
sicherheit als fernsehteam
er war sehr freundlich und freute sich
an diesem tag für diese gruppe sein zu
können
leider wussten wir nicht dass das so was
geschehen würde
das war sehr lärmig in thun und nach
einer weile konnte nur miteinander fast
nicht mehr kommunizieren
hans kammer war immer sehr aufmerksam
sehr sehr besorgt dass dass es uns allen
gut geht das habe ich bemerkt
wir kennen gelernt wo zum
vorstellungsgespräch noch bei jeder
coach ich niemals ich mir 2005 xi dahin
das erste mal getroffen
mit dem vorstellungsgespräch und ein
sehr guter hinterland hatte gleich
ziemlich verantwortungsvolle position
christen chef sie vom vom innenausbau in
frieda und hat es sehr gut gemacht
es ist eine der größten baustellen
europas sie also sehr schwierige
baustelle gefährlicher waren sehr
schwierig heraus ist natürlich prestige
objektiv rede tunnelbauer botschaft an
diesem tag war die lüftung defekt glaube
ich im tunnel von dem was ich verstanden
habe und daher war die luft ziemlich
stinkig oder vielleicht war das wasser
heiß heißer als gewöhnlich von dem was
ich gehört habe und als wir uns im zuge
befanden auf den weg zum tageslicht da
hat sich ein mitglied des bauteams der
mit uns vorsichtig so wohl gefühlt und
hans kabel der zuständig war für die
sicherheit hat sich dann schieden die
tür offen zu lassen damit etwas mehr
luft rein kommt die hans kabel stand vor
dieser tür offenen tür beim fahren damit
niemand
vielleicht stürzen könnte und ich habe
ihn gesehen und es ist ich weiß nicht
wie das stattgefunden hat aber plötzlich
war nicht mehr da ich habe geschrien
ist jemand gestürzt stop stop
wären alle versucht alles versucht zu
machen und ihnen das blut um ihn zu
retten
er ist nicht einfach gestürzt werden
dafür unaufmerksam war möglicherweise
möglicherweise hang etwas hin etwas
vielleicht die lampen das radio etwas
und ist hängen geblieben
das ist davis es mutmaßungen ich weiß es
nicht
als virus raus fuhren aus dem tunnel
es waren dutzenden von menschen dort die
alten gehört das was passiert war
und wartet einfach und waren
eine mit tränenden augen da habe ich
bemerkte da ist ein mensch gestorben der
sehr beliebt und bekannt für